my girlfriend's dog went out pitbull and
was very friendly to children and he
said he said that dog all right I said
she's great with kids because I'll eat
that dog if he touches my kid Mike I got
it and she goes oh John stop it but he's
a guy who's ready to fight and dealing
with a lot of energy I like to see that
there's no very bad guy and I'd be like
hey I'm so crazy I will eat your dog and
[ __ ] you up if that dog bites my dad I
understand cuz you know why when if you
guys don't have kids you understand when
something like that happens with your
child
yeah the sense of fury you do not have
the vocabulary to express and how down
York to [ __ ] anything and anyone up if
something harms that kid that's right so
when he went i will eat that dog I get
it yes I would have eaten and I would do
the same every single morning I run
there's some bold biker goes get on the
right path if my guy try to fight you or
kind of stop and I sure did
I sure did I'm gonna take his bike and
throw it into the Thames what happened
he was just he was just being a dick and
in full gear I'm like oh I'm sorry
Maternity Yeah right for a Tour de
France or something why are you in all
one unit that bothers me too why you
have a camel back on that that bugs me
hey I got an idea they're out in the
wilderness he goes how about I pull your
pants down and I [ __ ] you in the ass and
the guy goes excuse me he goes I'll pull
your pants down I'm gonna [ __ ] you
against that rock I'm trying to be tough
are you gay no I'm gonna show him who's
boss do you know what the guy hey Manuel
suck my dick babe stop I don't seem so
good
no I'm talking like a pro right and you
know you know my friend said and you
look at me
boys gay well well in heat when he gets
mad he [ __ ] you
and he boys get he's a big guy and you
know what the guy looked at him said the
guy goes no the guy goes you got it know
what to do cuz the guy being on my
friend's big and he goes I'm 48 years
old cowboy tie cowboy have leather
cowboy halfway how guys are like how in
the element this is only relating maybe
is a [ __ ] his mouth this is 5th grade
this is 5th grade and I cut off baggy
jeans shorts
not short jean shorts I didn't want to
get [ __ ] should have I had long shot
when I got better but wrong jeans are in
the area for this and Jordan on my feet
yeah I was like the Pharrell of fifth
grade oh yeah and I showed up and I
swear to God
kids were like we were playing
basketball like no no like you can't
play them like I don't understand why I
can't play like well you have a cowboy
hat on in a silk shirt yeah just
startling you see the J's though right
you're dressed like a giant piece of
candy and then you know I did the next
day wore my cleats we'll see what's up
at recess when there's only one ball
it's Thursday football boy we're gonna
cease making fun like in the silk shirt
oh boy did some work you did some work
rejent caught you could cut I could play
some ball and then there are my friends
like I well you're obviously clearly gay
properly yeah just so you're accept and
for the record though you're 100%
straight I think so okay I'm like Tom
forged a oh what's that I'm moving to
Seattle who want full-blown gay cuz he
said rain makes him gay love tequila
so I was like she's like huh yeah
careful what the girls drunk cuz she's
gonna be all yeah
careful with the forgot about my truth
oh yeah it was an issue they have long
nails oh yeah the girl with calluses you
know [ __ ] why are you doing power clean
and [ __ ] snatches and you have
freaking calluses all of your hands yeah
careful with my dong you know I'm saying
it ain't a barbell right it ain't a
barbell it's not the the gas on a
motorcycle a water moccasin versus a
water snake so the moccasin is venomous
the water snake is not people talk
oftentimes misidentify a venomous snake
for nominate it looks similar though
yeah I really really do we try to
educate people about the differences why
you want to never try to handle any
snake but why you want to identify them
properly so people aren't out there
trying to kill these animals you don't
need to be afraid of them you just need
to respect what they are and if we can
get an educational episode out of not
catching this giant turtle and what that
episodes done around 10 million views
amazing which we would have never
guessed we got this great like 11 minute
enter episode and had so much fun
searching the swamps for these snakes
and you always get something we don't
ever show up to a location and get
skunked we may not get what we were
after but we always managed can you tell
the difference in a water moccasin and a
water snake at a glance absolutely I
could probably tell you blindfolds are
they as poisonous as a rattlesnake well
they're venomous that's that's another
misconception that you have to know
there's venom and there's poison and
snakes are venomous so venom is injected
into your system through like fangs or a
stinger right and venom acts much
differently than poison and water
moccasins are not as toxic as some of
the rattlesnake species we have here in
the United States but it's it's enough
so that it's all how your body reacts to
venom right so you could be bitten by
something venomous and and really be
okay if you didn't go to the doctrine
and we always recommend if you're bitten
by something like like rattlesnake or
water moccasin you could be okay
potentially you could I have friends
that I know experts that have been
bitten by Western Diamondbacks which
have some of the most toxic venom in the
United States and they've just waited
out to see how their body reacts now
we're gonna dry bite maybe they didn't
have as much fun know there can be a dry
bite which is good that you know that
but you never know a dry bite you can
never be too careful always got it you
always got to seek help and as soon as
your arms start swelling up you know
that venom has entered your system it's
just a matter is your body going to be
able to fight that off
Wow like I was bitten by Gila monster
not intentionally and it is the worst
pain I have ever really needs more than
the treasure you're a big guy I feel
like a Gila monster may put you on the
ground I want no part of that yeah no
nobody thought they'd of like ooze out
of their mouth like a comic book glisten
one thing because they say that only a
fool in my healing I did first of all I
pronounce it Gila monster but he loves
but if correct me wrong their fangs are
in the back of their mouth are they not
know their reasons mouth yeah all
through they don't have thinks they have
teeth they're like razor blades and
they're turned backwards right so
imagine your hand going into a bear trap
and it's like a bulldog it is like the
Bulldog of the lizard world they don't
let go and the thing is you are pulling
it off the problem with all of this is
that I get this feeling that I have
- before I die I have to have the coyote
Peterson experience I got to put my we
can have an adventure today I feel like
I'm kind you deal this all the time like
because I feel like people watching all
I would do them like would you do that
same thing with people I could beat that
guy up in that gun could you would you
actually do it if someone gave you a
contract would you jump in there and do
it you know what I feel like every every
male goes I would do that I guarantee
you if that tarantula hawk is in that
container going dude you spouts off the
walls
you'd go forget this already nervous
already
I would not do it and by the way what's
funny is that you chose to do the fleshy
that the kind of like tender part of
your form that for me that if you were
to say Brian you there are two places
there's no way I'm gonna get stung for
whatever reason the end of my big toe
yeah and my fingertip right and of
course the neck would hurt to the neck
the neck all day that means the neck are
you kidding me a transit Hawk on your
neck I guess that would be buried maybe
we should shoot this episode like we can
we get our plane tonight got Arizona
huge
would you do it no no no that's not for
me now I don't do well with Museum they
probably have a broker at irrational hog
broker yeah if you guys can find a trans
law broker let me know that's a lot of
time and pain and agony right yeah I
know a guy but I want to get that all
the time those guys going dude I want to
get bit by an alligator this like I
would love to do that ah not not that
often a lot of people that would be like
oh I I think I could you could do that
and it's nothing I'm not saying I could
right I'm just saying that I have a I
there's a nagging I feel the challenge
clearing its throat in the back up is it
like the Mount Everest thing no I really
never added up there that's a good very
good question it's not even that it's
making these handles I yeah maybe it's
because it feels it's I'm intensely
afraid of it it feels like it'd be so
uncomfortable but I just want to do it I
would almost do it in private to see if
I could I kind of want to experience
that bright brilliant pain
you know other fight you know I've
always been scared to fight as far as
scared like I always been like God I
hope I hope you know because I was so
scared to lose except felt a lot of
pressure but there's that you know you
look at the the Roy Nelson fight the cro
cop fight chase Gormley I was so nervous
because the front my home home crowd I
felt like if I lost that fun I want to
have a career at all and it's right
after I lost to Rory it just depends on
the fight man there's times where I was
excited for sure and happy happy happy
czar tough out you know what I'm
ultimate fighter I was happy uh to fight
because ignorant is bliss right because
I didn't I didn't I've never experienced
the the the Fighting's all about peaks
and valleys I've never experienced those
valleys it's all I fight I win I fight I
win similar with Ronda she fights she
went she fight you win when you lose
let's when he find out what exactly this
sport is about and when you're when
you're winning it's like oh my god this
is great you hadn't it you've been
playing anything you bleep golf bowling
team bout anything you are done when
you're good at it and you're constantly
winning like dude this is the best thing
ever and when you lose think of video
game we think if you're playing video
game you can't say we're losing like
[ __ ] this game I don't what now in
fighting team but you know if you're
always winning I tell ya this is awesome
man and then when you lose you like oh
my god this sucks and that's fighting
there's no higher highs there's no lower
lows it it is the loneliest gig in the
world